oui bonjour du mit merci bonjour à
toutes et à tous notre invité ce matin
et henri cage bonjour bonjour bonjour et
donc vous êtes le président de l'uds
race l'union régionale des associations
du secteur social et médico social
vous êtes également président de
l'adapei une association qui oeuvre
également dans ce domaine et qui cette
année marque ses 50 ans d'existence
alors henri cage on va sommairement
présenter duras vous le dirais quelles
sont vos principales missions puis
ensuite nous viendrons sur ce thème d'un
webinaire que vous organisez aujourd'hui
donc et qui s'intéresse au coeur
finalement de l'action de cet organisme
face à la crise sanitaire alors lui rase
donc regroupe 23 associations
gestionnaires d'une soixantaine
d'établissements de ce secteur social et
médico-social et en tout vous occuper
près de 8000 personnes c'est ça en
situation de handicap ou des personnes
âgées ou encore en situation d'exclusion
quelques précisions sur les actions de
l'ue race henry cage d'abord autant fait
donc lui rase c'est une association qui
sait une tête de réseau
nous nous fédérerons toutes les
associations du secteur social et
médico-social donc lui rase et crier
depuis 1978 et nous nous accompagnons en
tout cas toutes les associations du
secteur
mais nous avons aussi nous avons aussi
des activités nous avons quand même
trois pôles d'activité donc un pôle
formation
nous avons ensemble de formations leaf
mais ce qu'ils forment dans les meetings
aux métiers du secteur social et médico
social
nous avons le pôle handicap donc qui et
c'est on trouve cap emploi et qui qui
accompagne en tout cas les personnes
dans les personnes en situation de
handicap à l'emploi vers l'emploi ou en
formation aussi et on nous avons aussi
des cellules d'accompagnement pour les
jeunes qui sortent de daisy m pro donc
et on les accompagne
ça peut être en formation pour le
premier pas vers l'emploi nous avons
aussi un service dans le des 2h c'est un
dispositif d'accompagnement des
apprentis en situation de handicap
voilà elle me disait vous êtes président
lui rase et président également de
l'adapei une association elle qui
s'occupe des personnes qui accompagnent
des familles donc pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et c'est justement
cette expérience ce retour d'expérience
que vous êtes venu nous faire ce matin
et que vous ferez également avec ce
webinaire qui sera organisée tout à
l'heure parce que effectivement le
travail social a été très fortement
impacté et finalement est au coeur de
cette crise d'abord sanitaire mais
ensuite économique et sociale que nous
vivons depuis un an
henri cage oui tout à fait donc si je
prends l'exemple de l'adapei de nos
établissements sein de l'adapei donc
avec 50 ans d'expérience on rappelle
quand même donc vous étiez déjà rodé
mais là c'était une idée ben oui oui
tout à fait ça c'est choquant qu'on
repense à nos manières de fonctionner
sans et
je veux pas qu'on perde de vue nos
missions donc même avec la crise nous
sommes obligés de remplir nos missions
et dont les établissements d'hébergement
en tout cas sont cependant le premier
confinement ont été maintenus ouverts
tandis que les autres établissements
d'accompagnement les accueils de jour on
a mis des choses en place par exemple
des systèmes de d'accompagnement chez
chez les personnes directement ou des
des systèmes de d'appels téléphoniques
ou en poney en tout cas la température
de toutes ces personnes que nous
accompagnons ouais mais vous avez dû
avoir très vite un surcroît de travail
et vous avez dû vous vous adaptez vous
le disiez y compris parce que des
pratiques professionnelles elles mêmes
ont été percutés alors comment avez-vous
fait face alors que votre principale
mission
justement vous le disiez tout à l'heure
c'est un accompagnement mais en principe
en accompagnement au plus près et puis
vous avez eue a donc non seulement
devoir vous adapter à cette nouvelle
manière de faire face à un public qui
lui aussi a été enfin la situation pour
certains cas dans certaines familles
devenues comment dirais-je a pris des
allures de catastrophe quoi faut faut le
dire non enfin on pouvait en témoigner
plus de cantine pour les enfants très
rapidement plus distribution alimentaire
les transports en commun fortement
impacté on l'a vu et puis les petits
boulots des fois qu'ils viennent
compléter aussi parce que tout ça il ya
une incidence budgétaire quoi pour les
foyers
ben oui tout à fait c'est un coup remet
un coup supplémentaire mais au-delà de
ça
c'est c'est quand même remplir remplir
leurs missions pour lesquelles nous
sommes nous sommes là et
on a pu mettre un peu mixer le
télétravail par exemple les éducateurs
spécialisés pouvaient entrer en relation
avec avec les familles par le biais du
téléphone ou nous accompagnons aussi bon
exemple à l'adapei des polyhandicapés à
bien les les salariés se déplacer en
tout cas oui c'est ça le public de pouce
il va toujours en la maintenant à des
pratiques nouvelles
l'objectif c'était quoi atténuer les
effets de l'éloignement voire peut-être
dans certains cas des des risques de
rupture de contact mais oui tout à fait
quasi la fête tout à fait puisque tout
le monde le sait c'est inédit
donc il faut il faut que nous soyons
inventifs
il faut qu'on soyons dans l'innovation
mais ne s'est pas toujours évident mais
en tout cas nous avons pu tant bien que
mal mener à bien nos missions et
on peut dire que on n'a pas eu tellement
de 2k défaillance majeure c'est ce que
voulait dire c'est aussi pour souligner
un peu justement cette cette forme
d'expérience qui a pu limiter les dégâts
que vous allez faire parce que on l'a
pas dit mais je rappelle donc le thème
du webinaire et on va en parler
puisqu'on a un enfant d'un entretien le
thème ses impacts de la crise sanitaire
sur le travail social entre protection
et autonomie comment accompagner en
présentiel et justement en distance y
est dense hier oui tout à fait donc ben
oui c'est donc chaque depuis cinq ans
depuis sept ans lui rase met en place ce
qu'on a appelé ce que nous appelons les
rendez vous de lui rase et cette année
le thème est devenu vraiment à propos
quoi bon puisque il nous faut repenser
et l'accompagnement de de toutes ces
personnes en situation de handicap ou en
marge de la société
donc à partir de ce rendez-vous de ce
matin donc nous aurons des
professionnels qui vont nous faire un
retour sur le sait ça sur les retours
d'expérience
deux travailleurs sociaux dans la
combinaison ils ont pu appréhender
appréhender appréhendés sur cette
situation
on va conclure mais ça a été plus un
travail de simplification où finalement
il vous a fallu quand même finalement
dans ses pratiques nouvelles aller vers
la complication
ça peut pas être cette filiation pas du
tout mais au contraire c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué parce que nous avons des
salariés qui qui ont peur et qui ont
peur il faut qu'ils aillent qu'ils
aillent en contact donc il faut que nous
soyons au point 2 pour les rassurer en
tout cas et que nous mettions en tout
cas tous tous les moyens toute la
sécurité autour puisque bon il peut ils
ont peur d'être des traîtres d'être
malade mais aussi d'aller porter cette
ce virus au point des personnes qu'ils
accompagnent ce sont des personnes déjà
fragile voilà c'est ce que je vais vous
dire c'est des personnes encore plus
fragilisés aussi donc il ya aussi cet
aspect écologique c'est pas c'est pas
plus facile mais vraiment plus compliqué
alors ce webinaire il est grand public
ce n'est pas réservé tout à fait donc
les on devait normalement faire une
inscription dont il y avait une date
limite mais maintenant le grand public
peut aller sur la page facebook de lui
rase par exemple et puis s'inscrire sur
un site unique voilà jusqu'à la lie ce
matin ils se battent aussi peuvent voilà
alors sur la page facebook
ça commence à 9 heures neveu avec une
première table ronde
et puis c'est donc ça dure la matinée
jusqu'à jusqu'à jusqu'à midi donc tous
ceux qui sont intéressés par ce sujet
donc peuvent aller sous la plage aller
s'inscrire il y aura le lien et ils
pourront suivre ce webinaire très
intéressant pour des retours
d'expérience voilà impact de la crise
sanitaire sur le travail social entre
protection et autonomie comment
accompagner dans ces temps difficiles en
présentiel et andy essentielle
voilà c'est donc ce thème qui est au
coeur de ce webinaire ce matin organisé
pour les 7e septième rendez vous de leur
septième rendez-vous de merci henri cage
président de l'uad d'avoir répondu à nos
questions bonne journée
merci